vamos a pensar en lo que significa sumar
números y para eso vamos a empezar con
algo muy sencillo cuántos serán 1
más
1 y pongamos el símbolo de igual para
que nosotros logremos esto podemos
pensarlo de diferentes maneras y podemos
decir cuántos era una cosa más una cosa
en este caso una cosa la representaremos
con digamos un círculo morado vamos a
colocarlo
este será nuestro círculo a morado será
una cosa y dado que sumaremos una cosa
más colocaremos ahora digamos otro
objeto que será un círculo azul dado que
lo puse con un color azul denme un
segundo
aquí está el objeto color azul
así es que tenemos uno más uno y uno más
uno cuantos círculos en total ahora
tengo bueno pues ahora tengo dos
círculos uno dos puedo decir que ahora
tengo dos círculos uno más uno será
entonces igual a dos y ustedes me pueden
decir bueno eso está muy sencillo qué
les parece si hacemos esto con números
mucho más grandes
así es que digamos que ahora tenemos un
signo de interrogación
vamos a colocar aquí un signo de
interrogación porque no sabemos a cuánto
equivale la siguiente suma
colocaremos el signo de más y ahora
colocaremos el número 3
y cuánto será 23 no lo sabemos por eso
tenemos aquí este símbolo los invito a
que ustedes pausa en el vídeo y lo
intenten también por su lado
bueno aquí podemos ver esto de la
siguiente manera tenemos dos objetos y
le voy a sumar tres objetos más cuántos
objetos tendré en total ustedes tienen
aquí dos objetos los cuales vamos a
representar también con círculos morados
uno
y ahora a estos dos objetos le sumaremos
otros tres objetos y los voy a
representar con círculos azules dado que
bueno escribí el número tres con un
número azul
traeremos uno
cuántos círculos ahora tendré en total
bueno pues los podemos contar tendremos
1 2 3 4 5 es más le colocaré el número a
cada uno y los volveré a contar tenemos
45 así es que 232 cosas más otras tres
cosas son cinco cosas nuestro signo de
interrogación va a ser igual a cinco así
es que vamos a borrarlo
y colocaremos la respuesta 23 será igual
a 5
y eso es correcto nos vemos en otro
vídeo